Rigo courgette ricotta and mint
bruschetta for this recipe you'll need a
griddle pan an essential piece of kit
for that char grill look
cut thick slices of Geppetto bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper and
griddle each side until toasted then
slice a couple of courgettes diagonally
into half a centimeter thick pieces
drizzle and coat in olive oil and season
with salt and pepper sear on a smokin
hot griddle pan in batches until all the
cadets are bar marked on both sides next
roughly chopped mint leaves and combined
with creamy ricotta cheese spread your
toes eto patter with dollops of minty
ricotta and top with your seared
courgette super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we do get the shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto no I haven't
actually
slots please into the pan for Delly add
a sprinkle of salt and pepper along with
a couple of crushed cloves of garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important to have your stock
gently boiling away reading cold stock
on top of the rice all the time it just
slows down the process generally you
cook a nice wide flat pan if you cook in
a deep pan all the rice sort of cooks at
different temperatures what stuck is
that in there dad cuz that's a vegetable
stock yeah because you can't have
different stocks it's all vegetarian
Chinese no chickens I made that mistake
once putting beef stock in a vegetarian
soup now I didn't Mathilde sure I'm
positive I'm joking
rough time how nice is that smell it
smells delicious ricin that's a bit of a
different rice this is our boy rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto now it's
really important to sear the rice if we
would just put the stock in without
sweating off the rice goes all starchy
so keep on Stanford Adi it's gonna make
it fun no flambe on the risotto to go
with our deep red beetroot theme I'm
adding red wine followed by the first
ladle of stock to get things started
now we're off Wow giving it cloudy sort
of look what's happened to the stock
this stock is reducing down and the rice
is sucking its it that's right
so the rice is actually getting nice and
plump one risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking here we
have to cook it all the way okay ready
for the next ladle I'm ready
good girl here we go ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way eat roots peel them rub them lil bit
of salt and sugar a little bit of age
bossman believer in there roasted them
I'm the great my parmesan how's that
vice doing rice is doing good now that
is exactly where you want to be now long
ago that nice glossy textured rice so
beetroot want you to put 2/3 of beetroot
in there for me saving 1/3 for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there
please all over rice like it's snowing
yeah and then we're just gonna get some
nice butter in there the butter gives
the risotto a really nice loss look at
that beautiful let that come down let it
come down first my knees pretty in there
now honey usually there you get
wonderful shake it
risotto should be like lava just flows
out and then the rest of the be room on
top
some extra-virgin olive oil
I'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table okay let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious cause yet ricotta and mint top
bruschetta an anxious roasted beet root
and time risotto a delicious non meat
feast that will have vegetarians and
carnivores fighting for seconds lights
is vegetarian night meg how is it done
really tasty however I really like
making the risotto
we have fun so where's Hani disco disco
zombie nice the hugger is terribly no
meat vegetarian vegetarian